The new MacBook is the result of a collective obsession...
...to simplify its essential components to create the most efficient design possible.
It's a product that couldn't exist without invention across many disciplines.
A Retina display delivers the very best viewing experience.
To engineer the thinnest Retina screen for Mac, we've refined every component...
...from the glass down to the pixels.
The result of all of this is a product that's only 13.1 millimeters thick...
...and weighs just two pounds.
To create a new MacBook, we were uncompromising in its design and engineering.
We set a new standard for portability while enhancing its fundamental components...
...to deliver what we believe is the best MacBook yet.